[Music]
get ready because you will not believe
that some of the harmful effects these
common food combinations can have on
your health if you eat them in high
amounts stay tuned to find out why you
should ditch your tomato and cucumber
salad and go with something healthier if
you're new here give this video a big
thumbs up and subscribe to our Channel
now let's explore some food combinations
that can ruin your health bananas and
milk if you're into fitness and love
your morning smoothie bowls or a
refreshing milkshake there's a good
chance you've had bananas and milk
before bananas have tons of fiber and
milk comes with a lot of calcium so it
could possibly go wrong
the truth is although it's one of the
best breakfasts out there it's really
not that healthy for you when the two
ingredients are combined health experts
are starting to warn people of the
effects of bananas and milk might have
when combines together bananas and milk
mixed together I've been judged as heavy
foods that might cause suggestion
problems if consumed regularly some food
specialists recommend taking milk and
consuming a banana 20 minutes after as
bananas are full of fiber which will
ease your digestion but combining
bananas and milk can hinder your
digestion process and disturb your
sleeping pattern on top of that eating
bananas with milk can produce toxins
that might cause a sinus congestion and
make you more prone to having a cold
cough or even allergies there might be a
very sweet and fulfilling morning
breakfast but when it comes to your
digestion you might experience an issues
and imbalances in your system what is
recommended is to make sure that the
banana is very ripe and add digestion
stimulating foods to your milkshake or
simply eat a banana on its own these can
be anything from cardamom nutmeg to
ginger and chia seeds hey guys we are so
excited to announce we are producing our
own original content head over to the
trendy for the best DIY fashion tips
makeup acts and so much more we are sure
you're going to love it and be sure to
let us know what you think in the
comment section we love to hear from you
their wine and dessert most of us love
to treat ourselves with a dessert and a
glass of wine after a particularly
unsuccessful day wine has been noted as
a healthy option when consumed in
moderation but what happens when you
combine it with dessert
although this particular combination
might be good for our soul and make us
feel better after a horrible day it
might make things worse for our body in
the long run wine and dessert often
don't go together because the taste of
one item can completely overpower or
change the taste of the other for
example you can only pair certain types
of wine with chocolate while wine and
blue cheese should never be combined
with the main reason why this
combination is completely awful for you
in the first place is because desserts
and wine both contain high elements of
excess sugar that gets converted into
fat and leads to weight gain when
consumed regularly this could lead to
serious heart problems and other health
issues connected to eating too much fat
you should try pairing up wine with
veggies to balance out the sugar levels
or simply limit the consumption to a
minimum and replace it with healthier
options don't forget that when you treat
yourself you should treat your body -
and make sure you're not harming it
along the way tomatoes and pasta we're
pretty sure this might break the heart
of any Italian foodie or simply anyone
who enjoys putting a tomato and cheese
sauce on your pasta pasta without tomato
sauce just sounds awful doesn't it well
it might save you from long-term
diseases if you consume the meal
regularly you might harm your body in
more ways than you know usually our
bodies receive tons of energy after a
healthy meal have you ever noticed that
tomato and cheese sauce combination on
pasta makes you sleepy and tired it's
the effect of the three ingredients
combined as they definitely don't work
together
tomatoes are considered to be acidic and
when combined with starchy food like
pasta they halt the production of the
enzyme that's needed to break down the
heavy starch this is why you often get
tired and incredibly bloated after
eating pasta with tomatoes and cheese
your body needs a lot of energy to
digest the food and in exchange it is
fatigued and exhausted when you add
dairy into the mix you only enhance the
potential digestion issues and only slow
down the process and it's not just pasta
any starch has the same effect on the
body when combined with tomatoes to
avoid bloating and other digestion
issues replace the sauce with a
healthier option like pesto which will
give you more energy black tea and milk
British people listen up it's time to
stop adding milk to your tea is
estimated that 98% of Brits take their
tea with milk with the secret to the
perfect brew being to put in the
first and then of the teeth along with
the hard protection benefits of drinking
tea a splash of milk can keep up with
your daily dose of calcium and vitamin
b12 but that's not always the case with
certain types of tea black tea comes
with many health benefits and it's known
to be really good for your heart but
adding in the milk could completely ruin
those benefits the chemicals found in
milk can modify the biological
activities in tea which as a result can
decrease the actual health benefits of
the drink molecular biologists carried
out a research on 16 women volunteers
and measured the effects of drinking
black tea with milk and plain hot water
results showed that black tea promoted
dilation of the blood vessels but when
milk was added to the test it completely
stopped the dilation the test has also
been done on both cow and soy milk and
the results were exactly the same it was
also noted that in this case taking tea
with milk doesn't even offer our calcium
boost nor does it absorb milk proteins
instead of milk and lemon steer tea and
increase the amount of antioxidants and
vitamins your body can absorb tuna with
mayonnaise and it's not just tuna with
mayonnaise the same goes for all fats
combined with wrong foods it's not
always a good idea and it doesn't always
work to your house benefit in fact if
you love tuna with mayonnaise on the
sandwich salad or any other recipe you
have to make sure the amount of mayo you
add to it is appropriate since tuna
comes with tons of protein along with
digestive chemicals it can cause an
unwanted reaction when mixed with fats
like mayo which require a breakdown of
liver and gallbladder salts large
amounts of fat like mayonnaise can cause
slow digestion when mixed with protein
like tuna of course you can still eat
them but you have to make sure you're
creating the right balance between the
two ingredients that will not only
benefit the taste but also your
long-term health this also applies to
eating bread with olives needs it's
fried in vegetable oil and many other
common combinations we don't usually
think about what you should do instead
is make sure you're using unrefined oils
like olive or coconut oil when cooking
vegetables and eat raw leafy green
vegetables like spinach when eating fats
so throw in a good amount of spinach to
balance your tuna and Mayo salad and
you'll be good to go and back on track
fruit with meals eating fruit with meals
is not a common habit but if you
frequently indulge in this combination
it's best to stop or consider some of
the alternatives some combinations that
might be harmful to your health include
adding large amounts of strawberries on
your salad covering fish with mango
salsa or eating apple pie for dessert
the reason behind it is that fruit goes
through the stomach fairly quickly but
it takes its time to digest in the
intestines when you combine it with
heavy foods that take much longer to go
through the digestive system it will
digest
even slower and since fruits come with
high amounts of sugar it will bring
counterproductive benefits to your
health instead of combining fruit with
your meals you should always eat at 30
to 60 minutes before a meal this will
allow it to prepare your digestive tract
and help your stomach work its way
through the amount of food you'll be
eating the enzymes will activate the
chemical process of digestion and allow
you to feel less tired and less bloated
after a heavy meal fruits should also
never be eaten after a meal for the same
reason you should always wait at least
three hours before you consume any fruit
after a meal it's always best to eat
fruit in the morning as it can sometimes
last for up to 10 hours to digest it
grapefruit or limes and cough medicine
have you want a cold lately you might
want to pay attention to the fruit you
consume if you take cough medicine it's
important to note that it should never
be combined with fruits like grapefruit
no matter how many health benefits it
might have consuming grapefruit or limes
with certain medicine can cause serious
chemical imbalances that will stop the
medicine from healing your body these
fruits come with high level of an enzyme
that's found in the gut and liver this
enzyme will deactivate some of the
effects of the medicine but increase
unwanted higher concentrations of the
drug which could lead to serious side
effects the researchers behind this
study have noted that the side effects
can include a heart block and an
abnormally rapid heartbeat the side
effects of kidney damage have also been
reported when a patient consumed a large
amount of grapefruit marmalade three
days before taking medicine sounds scary
right it's been reported that these
enzymes are found in all forms of
grapefruit including freshly squeezed
frozen and whole fruit having just one
whole grapefruit can increase the
concentrations of active drugs and
deactivate the most important healing
element that combats bacteria remember
to pay attention to what smoothies and
salads you're eating next time you feel
sick and need a vitamin boost stay away
from grapefruit fruit and flavored
yogurt while fruit and yogurt usually
aren't harmful for those without any
digestion issues this combination might
be completely unhealthy for people with
digestion issues we've previously talked
about the counterproductive effects
eating fruit can have on your body
yogurt is usually considered healthy but
try to stay away from those with fruit
at the bottom no matter how tempting
they might be yes the same ones you'd
sometimes get at school for lunch or by
yourself because the fruit is already
present although yogurt bowls are always
instagram-worthy and make for a
fantastic picture you could actually be
consuming too much sugar if you're not
choosing the right yogurt type with the
right amount of fruit fruit with
flavored yogurt can double or even
triple the sugar content you're eating
especially if you're consuming yogurt
with a sweetener it's also reported that
the coldness of the yogurt
can also have an effect on your
digestion this can result in stomach
pain and weight gain as it can take a
long time for the sugar to process in
your system it's also always best to go
with plain yogurt and mix it with fresh
fruit that will boost natural sweetness
instead of picking ready-made dairy that
comes with fruit at the bottom another
fun way you can combine yogurt with
fruit is to mix it with natural
sweeteners like lime and honey smack and
cheese
who doesn't love mac and cheese but
before you indulge in another plate you
might want to check where your mac and
cheese actually came from it turns out
that the combination of the ingredients
when mixed with a powder you'd get in a
box version of mac and cheese might not
be as healthy as we think especially if
you're expecting a baby a recent study
of 30 cheese products detected high
levels of chemicals called phthalates
which can disrupt male hormones and are
linked to birth defects when the meal is
consumed by pregnant women although the
presence of these phalates isn't banned
the Food and Drug Administration did
warn federal agencies to assess the
potential health risks they might bring
to those who are expecting a baby this
ballot is also found in block cheese and
other natural cheeses however it's been
noted that the powdered version from mac
and cheese mixes has the strongest
concentration due to the high levels of
processing while the amount of
phthalates is still fairly low it is
higher than the natural hormones in our
bodies which could cause harmful effects
later on we all know mac and cheese
isn't the healthiest food option in
general so it's best to stay away from
the boxed version you can easily whip up
in just a few minutes tomato and
cucumbers tomato and cucumber salad is a
refreshing choice that's often
considered healthy and we can totally
see why it doesn't leave you bloated it
gives you energy and it's perfect for
weight loss but is the combination
actually beneficial for your health in
the long term we've already mentioned
the acidity of tomatoes and the effect
they might have when combined with pasta
but tomatoes also have the same effect
on some of the vegetables you normally
put in your salad they come with an
enzyme that usually destroys vitamin C
especially when consumed in large
portions and since cucumbers are full of
vitamins adding tomatoes to your salad
can completely ruin the nutritional
benefits you thought you were getting
the acid released in the abdomen can
also cause numerous digestive problems
and can be one of the main reasons
behind irritable bowel syndrome also
known as IBS it doesn't sound that
nutritious anymore does it but don't
worry you don't have to completely ditch
your favorite tomato and cucumber salad
if you absolutely can't live without the
two ingredients to make sure your salad
is still nutritious and is able to break
down those vitamin C destroying enzymes
combine it with spinach chia seeds apple
cider vinegar and other and
that commonly combat bloating and of
course this is still a better choice
than some of the other combinations on
our menu today what's your favorite food
combination let us know in the comments
for more videos like this one check out
10 foods you'll never buy again after
knowing how they are made
see you next time
[Music]